[Musique]
la suite de notre émission spéciale
municipal sur france 3 franche comté on
traverse la région de part en part de
belfort à dole quatre candidats sont en
lice pour diriger la principale ville du
département du jura la quatrième de
franche comté
quatre candidats qui sont présents sur
notre plateau jean baptiste gagne où le
maire sortant aujourd'hui divers droite
mais investis par les républicains les
républicains qui est votre ancien parti
vous êtes aussi soutenu pour ce scrutin
par la république en marche le parti
présidentiel également sur ce plateau
aco hamdaoui membres de génération vous
êtes à la tête d'un collectif de gauche
avec le parti socialiste le parti
communiste et la france
insoumise hervé prat candidats avouent
d'europe écologie les verts anciens
maires des clans 90 petite commune près
de dole et dominique revoy tête de liste
vous de lutte ouvrière pour ce scrutin
municipal bonsoir à tous les quatre je
vous précise que david mal notre
confrère de flandre france bleu besançon
va nous écouter tout au long du débat il
interviendra en fin d'émission pour vous
poser quelques questions alors le tirage
au sort a désigné hervé prat pour
commencer c'est aussi vous qui
débuterait le tour de conclusion hervé
prat vous étiez maire je les dis d'une
petite commune à une douzaine de
kilomètres de dole vous n'avez
d'ailleurs pas terminée
votre mandat pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à dole aujourd'hui je me
présente pas ce qu'il y à d'urgence
écologistes et que moi j'étais candidat
en 1992 à l'époque on trouvait les
écologistes bien sympathique mais
utopique
c'était il ya 28 ans aujourd'hui face
aux tempêtes qui se succèdent face au
dérèglement climatique il faut agir et
le mieux c'est d'agir localement c'est
là où les idées écologistes sont les
plus applicable c'est pour ça que nous
avons choisi avec europe ecologie les
verts et puis aussi beaucoup de citoyens
puisque notre liste essentiellement
constitué de citoyens d'aller vers ces
élections jean-baptiste ganne you vous
êtes le maire sortant mais vous n'étiez
pas tête de liste lors du dernier
scrutin en 2014 vous avez pris la suite
de jean marie sermier en 2017 lorsque
celui ci a été réélu député ne pouvait
pas rester premier magistrat pour cause
de loi sur le cumul des mandats
quel est le sens de cette campagne
sur votre nom vous affranchir de la
tutelle bienveillante du député ou
rester dans la sa droite ligne je crois
que c'est pour le sujet le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir ce que nous
voulons pour cette ville depuis 2014 je
crois qu'une majorité nouvelle s'est
installée elle a montré ses capacités de
gérer cette ville d'abord avec jean
marie sermier pu avec moi même et
aujourd'hui tout le sens de la liste que
je conduis c'est de pouvoir proposer un
projet qui soit dans la continuité parce
que la ville depuis 2014
eh bien ces deux villes a changé et
l'idée de cette candidature c'est bien
sûr de poursuivre dans cette logique là
parce que dole a retrouvé une dynamique
qui était indispensable à quoi mme daoui
vous avez déjà exercé trois mandats au
conseil municipal de dole dans la
majorité lors du mandat du socialiste
jean claude ventes de dans l'opposition
avec quelles ambitions pour partait en
campagne
je voudrais déjà précisé pourquoi je
pense que la question c'est pourquoi je
me présente je veux dire que je suis né
à dole
j'ai grandi à dole je vis à dole je
travaille à dole ma fille est née à dole
et grandi à dole et j'ai donc vous
l'avez préciser j'ai servi ma ville en
tant que conseiller en leur en tant
qu'adjoint et le collectif qui s'est
construit lors de ces élections
constitué de citoyens de partie que vous
avez cités m'a désigné comme tête de
liste pour porter un projet novateur
dans sa construction et ambitieux dans
son programme alliant écologie et
justice sociale
voilà pourquoi je me présente sur ces
élections municipales à dole dominique
revoy lutte ouvrière présente une grosse
dizaine de listes
dont les grandes villes de franche comté
quelles sont vos ambitions vous pour ces
municipales à dole à dole les problèmes
cruciaux des travailleurs sont les mêmes
que partout ailleurs dans le pays à
savoir avoir un salaire correct et
pouvoir faire vivre dignement sa famille
or tous les aspects de la vie des
travailleurs sont attaqués aujourd'hui
que ce soit il y a le chômage la
précarité
on voit actuellement et retraites et la
santé
et c'est le résultat d'une véritable
guerre sociale qui est menée par la
bourgeoisie avec l'aide du gouvernement
alors oui je pense que dans ces
élections il faut faire entendre le camp
des travailleurs et c'est le titre de la
liste que je présente alors madame
messieurs dole semble avoir un problème
avec ses services publics menaces
récurrentes sur l'hôpital notamment le
service de chirurgie suspension a durée
indéterminée de la brigade anti
criminalité à quang ba oui je me tourne
vers vous que peut faire un maire pour
sauvegarder ses services publics se
battre se battre avec sa population et
pas se battre depuis sa tour d'ivoire
depuis son cabinet mes alliés toute la
population elle quand des mailles vite
que la municipalité sortante ne se bat
pas assez c'est ça vous sous-entendez la
méthode est pas bonne depuis 2014 je
peux vous citer tout ce qui a disparu on
à la réanimation qui a disparu en termes
de lit la chirurgie l'année rené roux
chirurgie la cardiologie la pneumologie
la pédiatrie la maternité la médecine
une ligne de smur la nuit les soins
intensifs tout ça a disparu 2002 puis
2014 sens a fait au total 100 lits 150
postes
la bataille le maire de dole nappe ne
s'est pas assez battu il ya des communes
comme la commune la commune de vierzon
qui a s'est battu avec sa population et
qui a sauvé sa maternité
on l'a juste pour terminer il ya encore
une menace aujourd'hui qui pèse très
fortement sur la chirurgie
conventionnelle et si la chirurgie
conventionnelle disparaît c'est des
services qui vont disparaître derrière
la maternité puisqu'il ya besoin de
chirurgie viscérale et
les urgences disparaîtront donc il faut
être plus combatifs pour sauver son
hôpital jean baptiste se gagnent ou vous
n'êtes pas assez combatif non moi je
suis assez étonné de ce que j'entende
monsieur hamdaoui à l'instant parce que
la réanimation elle a fermé avant ce
mandat donc vous étiez adjoint aux
finances à ce que je sache
et puis nous dire que la pédiatrie la
maternité a fermé fin faut arrêter de
raconter un peu n'importe quoi
la maternité elle fonctionne elle
fonctionne bien c'est un très bon
service vous m'avez pas entend déjà dit
que c'était maintenant laissez-moi jedir
il est pas faire ça fait quinze ans que
vous et vos amis manifesté dans les rues
de dole sent pas quand il fit culte et
c'est très inefficace et qui plus est on
a le mérite ne s'avoue oui mais il faut
c'est d'efficacité et je sens parce que
ce comportement qui vise à faire peur
régulièrement ça fait 3 municipal que je
fais ça fait 3 municipal qu'on nous
annonce est bien que l'hôpital va fermer
ainsi que la maternité donc je pense
qu'il faut les défendre nos services et
les chirurgiens sont très inquiets les
gens gagnent ou et il faut défendre nos
trois établissements de soins dole c'est
très important dont on a travaillé
fortement aussi avec le chu de besançon
pour avoir des nouveaux spécialistes qui
arrivent à l'hôpital de dole
c'est un combat quotidien mais je veux
pas ici que l'on croit que tout est en
train de fermer
comme régulièrement monsieur hamdaoui
cherche à nous lever hervé prat la santé
avec l'hôpital la sécurité avec la bac
quelles sont les marges de manoeuvre
d'un maire sur ces questions là et que
feriez vous à la place de jean baptiste
gagne ou je crois que il faut agir là où
on a des places c'est-à-dire au conseil
de surveillance
aujourd'hui la loi bachelot a beaucoup
limiter le poids des mères mais on peut
dans cette
cet endroit on peut informer la
population et les aider à se mobiliser à
travers notre place monsieur gagnon il
est soutenu par lrm mais ça lui donne
pas beaucoup de pouvoir en plus si
j'irai même c'est plutôt un boulet pour
lui parce qu'il est allé voir monsieur
castaner pour avoir des effectifs
supplémentaires
locher de l'intérieur voilà et donc
l'autre jour je suis passé au
commissariat de police ils m'ont dit mme
banon une façon monsieur gagnon pour
l'instant il n'a rien obtenu
alors je dis pas que moi en tant que
maire écolo je tiendrai plus mais je
pense qu'il faut agir autrement sur la
sécurité à agir plus en proximité avec
la population dans les quartiers en lien
avec les habitants
c'est à dire lié des habitants faire
régulièrement des conseils de quartier
avec les policiers les services sociaux
les services de l'éducation ils
régleront les prêts manucure mais par
contre vous pouvez et ça c'est mon
expérience de maire rural
quand y avait un problème et moi je
dirais gaudeul c'est un gros village me
suis rendu compte de plus en plus dense
ans cette campagne tout le monde se
connaît et des cadets l'idée qu'il ya
une incivilité il faut agir
immédiatement et là on peut faire agir
une police de proximité
je pense que on ne rend on ne fera pas
mieux je pense que monsieur gagne ou sur
la police nationale vient de le dire
mais non mais je j'en suis convaincue
par contre on fera mieux que vous sur
l'hôpital parce que je pense que vous
venez de dire que un maire n'a pas le
pouvoir d'agir directement sur l'hôpital
cette vision d'état et le maire il doit
être garant pour être vigilant sur la
situation des établissements de soins
sur le territoire juste l'argent insiste
gagne ce sont des décisions de l'état
l'état c'est aussi le gouvernement vous
êtes dans cette campagne soutenue à la
fois par le principal parti d'opposition
à l'assemblée nationale les républicains
et vous êtes soutenus par le parti
présidentiel la république en marche
est-ce que c'est pas un peu schizophrène
est ce que ça vous met pas en porte à
faux nom je sais que maintenant les
médias l'opposition veulent mettre des
étiquettes partisanes et politique à
tout le monde alors il ya beaucoup de
partis qui me soutiennent parti radical
moments libres de valérie pécresse
pourquoi parce que cette majorité
sortante elle s'est élargie et la tenue
elle est uni mail a fait ses preuves et
où je vous laisse les siens du
gouvernement ou non un opposant ce qui
est important c'est d'avoir localement
une majorité qui n'a pas d'âme et des
projets je veux ayant répondu à ma
question
il doit savoir rassembler et au delà des
contingences politiques des uns et des
autres moi j'ai mes convictions je suis
quelqu'un qui a des valeurs de droite et
du centre mali s'étaient déclarés divers
droite au ministère de l'intérieur alors
essentiellement les étiquettes
politiques ce sont des républicains qui
sont présents sur la liste mais ce n'est
pas ça qui va diriger demain la question
de l'avenir de notre ville la police
thomas s'amuser sur les hôpitaux c'est
de démanteler et de construire des
hôpitaux de proximité
soutenez vous madame butin dans sa
stratégie sur la république en marche ou
alors êtes vous du côté des républicains
qui combattent qui combattait la
république en marche comment vous vous
situez mais ce n'est pas le sujet celles
et ceux qui ont ce qu'ils offrent end
que non at il expliqué vous voulez pas
dire sept partisans du gouvernement ou
au prix c'est plus compliqué que ça il
ya des choses que le gouvernement fait
qu'ils sont mauvais et des choses qui ce
qu'ils sont bien qu'est ce que c'est que
cette situation aujourd'hui
être mère je vous le dis ce n'est pas
cela dans une ville moi j'ai ouvert la
porte à tout le monde pendant ces trois
années j'ai été maire jean marie sermier
auparavant et je m'inquiète d'entendre
que aujourd'hui ce sont les étiquettes
politiques qui vont faire des élections
municipales
ce n'est pas ça et bien des élections
ici pas ce n'est pas ça que d'être mère
donne comme dominique revoy pour lutte
ouvrière le maintien des services
publics évidemment une question
incontournable également oui alors sur
l'hôpital bon en réalité c'est quand
même tout le système de santé qui est
tous ces secteurs qui sont passés sous
la férule des grands groupes financiers
alors en particulier les hôpitaux
et c'est au nom de la dette à rembourser
que les services qui ont été cités ont
été fermés le diktat maintenance et de
rembourser ses dettes et c'est la
rentabilité
et c'est au nom de cette rentabilité que
les hôpitaux de proximité sont fermés au
profit de gros mastodontes régionaux qui
sont peut-être à la pointe du progrès
mais qui n'ont pas le personnel pour
faire fonctionner sauf qu'au passage sa
rose quand même des grandes entreprises
du btp et des trusts comme siemens ou
philips qui vendent du matériel médical
alors je dis cela pour dire que vous
comprenez bien que c'est un problème qui
dépasse largement le cadre d'une
municipalité et
pour se défendre il va falloir se battre
un tout autre niveau c'est à dire qu'il
va falloir à un moment donné se décider
à attaquer la bourgeoisie qui fait
passer ses profits avant la santé et
même avant la vie des gens et se battre
et attaquer le gouvernement qui la
soutient de toutes ses forces
allez on revient à dole et à vos projets
municipaux dans ce contexte de pression
sur les services publics comment dole
peut-elle rester attractif comment
attirer des emplois des habitants hervé
prat
quelles sont les mesures que vous
défendez en la matière moi je crois que
dole nady dijon ni besançon il faut
faire des projets adaptés à notre ville
et aux besoins de ses habitants
les projets de la mairie sortante de
monsieur gagne ou essai remis avant sont
surdimensionnés elles ont créé un fort
endettement nous parlons tout à l'heure
de la fiscalité qui très élevés pour les
deux lois donc je pense que nous nous
gérons sobrement cette ville avec une
volonté de rénover l'existant et de ne
pas avoir de nouveaux grands projets
pharaoniques
c'est vous pointez quoi comme je
pointerais dixinn et le complexe sportif
c'est à dire qu' il y avait un besoin
lindo sur notre commune pour le grand
dole aussi pour les enfants pour les
écoles mais il ya eu un projet
surdimensionné et ce projet
surdimensionné bakr et de l'endettement
il ya eu la volonté de créer une holding
aux halles d'exposition il y avait la
commanderie qui est un très beau
bâtiment ça suffisait fermerez vous de
l'expo souhaité mais nous vous savez on
va pas faire comme vous quand vous êtes
arrivé c'est à dire vous avez eu d'effet
ce que la précédente majorité rieffel
nous on va conserver l'existant mais on
agira sobrement avec l'existant donc
pour répondre
jean baptiste gagne ou non vous ne
fermerait pas dole exposé si vous êtes
élue - je suis pas pour gaspiller
l'argent public et une sur aquand ah oui
sur l'attractivité de dole donc
l'attractivité de dole ça va être le
résultat de ce qu'on va présenter dans
toute la soirée c'est le résultat d'un
programme
et qu'est ce qui fait qu'un territoire
est attractif qu'est ce qui fait que un
couple par exemple vient de s'installer
à dole qu'est-ce qui va regarder il va
regarder
est-ce que je peux me soigner est ce que
je peux faire soigner mes enfants est ce
que il ya une crèche est ce qu'il ya des
écoles est ce que mes enfants vont vivre
dans un environnement sain en fait c'est
le bilan en fait j'ai envie de vous
répondre en disant laisser se dérouler
le programme est reposé la question à la
fin est-ce que ce qu'on présente et
attractif ou pas voilà pour revenir sur
sur ce que vient de dire monsieur prat
puisqu'il a pointé du doigt c'est que
les projets pharaoniques qui ont été
faits il ya eu un avertissement de la
chambre régionale des comptes avant que
la piste ne se construisent en disant
attention vous allez grévé le les
finances de la ville pendant longtemps
vous hypothéquer l'avenir
non d'abord régionales oui bah c'est la
chambre et miou et vous avez cité de
l'expo de l'expo aussi de l'expo qui a
été construit sur à d'accord sur
l'analyse avant assure la jambe
régionales a averti avant que le projet
ne se montrent malgré tout vous avez
raté aussi vais aller voter
ce qui a fait exploser l'endettement
l'endettement de l'agglo mère annie rien
rajouté 2016 donne la traduction est
vener était déjà très dégradées nier
vous l'avez encore plus dégradée en
assurant des temps le dira en
surendettement les finances de
l'agglomération et jean baptiste gagne
ou avez vous mal géré la ville
non moi je voudrais parler
d'attractivité ce que c'était ça le
sujet j'ai deux choses à dire sur le
sujet mais répondait d'abord sur la
situation financière s'il vous plaît on
évalue on était là dessus et après je
vous donne la parole sur la tactique de
la gestion financière de la ville de
l'agglo reste de l'agglomération c'est
une gestion saine et la meilleure façon
de le constater ces deux choses d'abord
que la capacité de désendettement qu'est
le baromètre de toutes les collectivités
et dans tous les débats municipaux vous
en parler aujourd'hui il faut cinq
années et demie pour et bien désendetter
l'agglomération 6 ennemis pour la vie
n'est pas vrai et bien alors la saisie
7,7 pour les opérations non au 31
décembre 2010 9,7 ce chiffre qui est de
dix ans on est dans le jeu la vigilance
reste non à 12 ans on est envoyé lui
d'aller vous êtes bien par à 32 millions
pour parler de finance rangueil
la chambre régionale des comptes comme
hicham daoudi était adjoint aux finances
de la ville a décidé de mettre sous
surveillance notre ville parce que
l'endettement avait trop augmenté à la
ville de dole alors ça c'est des gt gts
qu'en mars jusqu'en avril 2014
jamais la chambre régionale des comptes
mais il eut me dit que sa copie du
document
voilà je voudrais paraît un peu
d'attractivité quand même de la ligue
qui me semblait être important sur
lequel je n'ai pas pu m'exprimer jusqu'à
maintenant je pense que cette ville elle
a su saisir l'opportunité de la
reconfiguration de la grande région
en replaçant d'oulu maximum au contact
dijon et besançon pour la rendre
attractive et si je le dis c'est parce
qu' un certain nombre de critères
simples nous le démontre la population
depuis trois ans augmente à nouveau
alors qu'elle a baissé pendant des
années y compris pendant que vous gérez
la ville l'économie va mieux le taux de
chômage était de 9 % en 2014 il est de 6
ennemis aujourd'hui on a réussi à
attirer de nouvelles entreprises
il ya deux grandes base intermarché et
colruyt qui vont être conservés qui vont
se développer sur lequel je voudrais
bien savoir monsieur prat quel est votre
avis sur le sujet parce que je vous
entends dû être quelque peu menaçant de
ce point de vue là est donc cette
dynamique ce changement d'image de notre
ville
eh bien nous devons poursuivre dans
cette logique là vous interpellez
monsieur prend à lui donner la parole et
merci vous allez fermer les bases
logistiques qui sont installés dans la
région doloise les projets en cours oui
mais il faut de la cohérence dans
l'aménagement du territoire c'est à dire
que quand on a les meilleures terres
agricoles donc dans la plaine de tableau
on va pas y mettre des bases logistiques
c'était destiné à une zone qui
s'appelait innovia c'est là on aurait dû
mettre l'usiné de méthanisation que j'ai
défendu à l'époque donc sous le
précédent mandat
mais non on l'a mis sur la zone de
breuvand à l'entrée de ces deux lois
peuvent se rendre compte aujourd'hui
encore les bastais qu'elles sont prévus
et qu'ils vont conserver développer mais
moi j'étais quand vous êtes arrivé aux
manettes j'étais content de voir par
exemple que la base intermarché qui
devaient être mis sur la zone de brement
allait aller à rochefort là où il ya
déjà des bosses ça c'était un début de
cohérence par contre aller mettre la
bosse de colruyt sur la rue mais tori de
travaux ses bases qui sont sur la zone
de riscle parmi nous je pense que la
zone de tao n'a pas à recevoir des bases
logistiques
c'est une zone innovia c'est son nom qui
moi je m'incline au travail et salaires
nerval ruyt et les emplois qu'on
pourrait créer on parce que c'est une
opportunité
ce gagnant pour le pouvoir d'achat pour
que des salariés trouvent du travail
léger la solution sous le nombre
d'écuries développement ce mandat à
venir et c'est indispensable s'ils
gagnent ils correspondent à pourvoir pas
laisser des friches industrielles des
friches commerciales
on va utiliser les friches de roches
noires et on va faire l'europe d'aller
s'installer sur les niches commerciales
mais évidemment évidemment la dette
publique c'est ça la puissance publique
elle accompagne les savez monsieur
gagnon intermarché ils vont ils sont
allés là on leur a proposé sous le
précédent mandat on leur pose poser
brevans à l'entrée de dole ils sont
allés à brevans et puis après bah vous
avez proposé au choix c'était une bonne
solution
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faudra il
faut il ne faut pas laisser abandonner
les fermes agricoles économiques dolois
et de la réalité les grandes surfaces
elles savent s'adapter aujourd'hui que
vous n'étiez pas d'accord sur ses
projets de développement économique
j'aimerais qu'on avance dans ce débat et
qu'on évoque l'environnement vous avez
tous des des projets en la matière et
notamment la question des transports
publics à quoi mme da oui vous vous
proposer la gratuité est ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer comment vous la
financer l'argent existe déjà puisque
sous le mandat le versement transport
ceux qui financent le bo payée par les
entreprises aux prises pour les projets
transports
absolument ce cette taxe est passée de
0,3 à 0,6 donc été mis au maximum de ce
que la loi autorise ce qui fait cinq
cent mille euros
de bonis pour
le grand dole là à périmètre constant
égale la gratuité coûterait 400 mille
euros voilà donc l'argent est là on va
remettre de l'ordre dans les lignes
budgétaires
ça a été pour quoi vous le faites
philosophiquement parlant
philosophiquement parlant on nous parle
de transition écologique il faut y aller
franchement on nous dit il ya une
urgence climatique et il faut y aller
faut arrêter de faire des petits pas y
aller franchement elle a pour vertu donc
de lutter contre les émissions de co2 en
réduisant la place de la voiture et en
même temps elle allie ce qui est fait le
coeur de notre programme
la justice sociale donc on allie deux
axes forts de notre programme transition
écologique et justice sociale
voilà et on veut y aller franchement
hervé prat vous n'êtes plus mesuré vous
demandez pas la gratuité ça fait pas
partie de votre programme vous parlez de
rendre les tarifs abordables
ben oui parce que moi je crois que pour
qu'un transport public qu'il soit
attractif
il faut qu'ils aient un résout donc
d'abord il faut reconstruire le réseau
que concassé l'équipe 2 messieurs
sermier fisher et gagne ou pour donner
envie aux deux lois et aux de l'oise de
prendre le bus et après on peut tendre
vers la gratuité mais c'est pas la
première étape et ce réseau c'est cette
refonte du réseau elle va coûter
il va coûter à la collectivité c'est
aussi la remise en place de services
gérés
si je résume les hyper et préféré plus
de bus que des bus gratuits ce
exactement si vous avez bien compris mon
raisonnement est c'est à dire que nous
on veut quand même parce que quand tu me
l'équipe de monsieur gagnon fischer
serbie est arrivé aux manettes
ils ont multiplié par trois le prix des
tarifs et ils ont démantelé le réseau de
bus donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est
diviser par deux parce que c'est vrai
que c'est trop cher l'abonnement pour
des familles modestes 100 euros c'est
beaucoup et ensuite surtout développer
le réseau mais il ya un axe je pense sur
lequel vous vous rendez pas compte
comment des personnes en particulier
qui sont je vois bien dans notre
campagne votre corps de si vous leur
envoyez une multitude de courrier les
personnes âgées des personnes âgées
si vous perdez l'élection à mon avis ça
sera ça c'est à dire que vous avez
abandonné le fait que les gens pouvaient
on allait les chercher à la demande vous
dans votre programme vous dites oh bah
on va faire du bénévolat s'est pas
exprimé sur ce thème vous aussi vous
prenez la gratuité et je vous donne la
parole après jean baptiste ganne youku
qui sait répondre
ben oui bien sûr ça me paraît la moindre
des choses et qu'on ne vienne pas me
parler d'argent de moyens des finances
et parce que l'argent pour le coup là y
en a et je reviens quand même sur la
question de l'attractivité pour laquelle
ou sur laquelle vous ne m'avez pas
interroger mais je tiens quand même à
dire que c'est une question qui est
faussée parce qu'en réalité elle elle
intéresse qui en tout cas pas les
travailleurs et retraités pauvres cons
pas de bus qui vivent dans des ghettos
dans des cités elle intéresse les les
entreprises avec l'idée toujours la même
que si ça va bien pour elle ça ira bien
pour la population la plus pauvre sa
personne n'y croit personne n'y croit
plus ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
nous la saur celle-là est en réalité là
plutôt que dérouler des tapis rouge aux
entreprises soit disant pour qu'elle
vienne s'installer crée des emplois ce
qu'elles ne font jamais cet argent
serait mieux pour la collectivité et en
particulier sa partie la plus pauvre
jean baptiste gagne où vous avez attaqué
a été attaqué sur votre bilan en matière
de transport je précise que monsieur
fisher qui a été cité c'est le président
de l'agglomération du mans je vous
laisse répondre voilà donc non mais bien
sûr
il ya beaucoup d'excès dans sur ce sujet
moi je crois que en 2014 on a été élu
sur le fait qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
bus qui était vide et qui circulait qui
pollué par ailleurs donc le réseau a été
reconquis gurs et moi ce que je propose
c'est un transport à la demande pour les
seniors associatif que nous mettrons en
place comme sur la communauté de
communes de champagnole qui a porté ses
fruits et qui a des résultats
je souhaite que nous ayons les premiers
transports à l'hydrogène
au cours du mandat ça c'est premier
transporteur n'a ni les moyens alors
jeudi les premiers ça veut dire que nous
ne pourrons pas dans les six ans que
toute la flotte des bus ce serait
excessif et moi je veux pas être dans la
démagogie de transport gratuit comme on
l'entend là ils sont jamais gratuit en
réalité je veux que on densifie sur
lignon où il ya beaucoup de zones
d'emploi qu'on assure le transport
scolaire c'est ce que nous avons fait au
cours de ce mandat et puis je vous dis
les premiers transports propres ce que
je pense qu'ils font qu'on réduise aussi
les gaz à effet de serre et les
transports publics permettez-moi de
compléter la seconde 20 secondes
parce que cette développement ces
transports gratuits avec évidemment
développement à terme du temps du réseau
de transport mais surtout retour de la
navette gratuite très demandé par les
seniors au centre-ville il faut que nous
offre cette navette vous avez essayé de
20 secondes les anglais madame messieurs
on arrive dans la dernière partie de
cette émission c'est l'heure
d'accueillir david mal de france bleu
besançon
bonsoir david alors je vous laisse vous
installer à côté de moi vous avez
attentivement le débat depuis le début
de l'émission qu'est ce que vous en avez
retenu et surtout quelles questions
complémentaires quelles questions qui
fâchent vous souhaitez poser à nos
invités a eu des échanges très
intéressants notamment sur
l'installation l'emplacement des
supermarchés mais j'ai d'abord une
question pour vous jean baptiste ganne
ue
après ses propos d'hervé prat qui a dit
l'étiquette lrm est un boulet pour vous
alors est-ce que ce soutien de la
république en marche et un boulet pour
vous dans cette campagne des municipales
non mais moi je ne rêve je ne raisonne
pas de cette manière et je pense que
vous savez quand vous êtes en proximité
tout au long d'un mandat comme je lé
fais avec les habitants ils savent ce
que j'ai fait ils savent ce que cette
majorité a fait et les étiquettes
politiques
quand on est sur le terrain et qu'on
conduit des projets on se pose pas la
question de savoir si ce projet il est
socialiste les communistes de la france
a soumises ou autre est la démonstration
la plus simple c'est que moi j'ai
accueilli beaucoup de gens de tendance
complètement différente de gauche qu'on
a accompagné dans le tissu associatif
dans des projets et je crois que ce qui
est nécessaire c'est ce réseau est de
cette manière
faut le faire sans vient imposer des
étiquettes aux uns et aux autres la
personne avec qui que ce soit c'est un
soutien qui vous est accordée par le
wild en série et je pense que c'est bien
d'avoir une majorité qu'ils soient
élargies sur une ville et que ce soit
pas du sectarisme en étant sur un seul
courant politique qui écarte tous les
autres alors une autre question pour à
quoi mme da oui vous êtes opposé tout à
l'heure à jean-baptiste ganne ue sur la
question des finances
vous avez aussi parlé d'hôpital moi j'ai
envie de vous poser des questions très
concrètes puisque vous reprocher à jean
baptiste gagne ou de ne pas se battre
assez pour la survie de l'hôpital
concrètement vous faites comment pour
attirer des médecins des praticiens à
dole il faut faire en sorte qu'on arrête
de dépecer l'hôpital de dole il faut
arrêter c'est pour ça que le les mets
des médecins les chirurgiens ne viennent
pas on supprime des lits on supprime on
supprime des services comment
voulez-vous que seul cet hôpital puisse
attirer des médecins mécontentement je
repose ma question si vous êtes maire
demain vous faites quoi pour attirer des
mécènes vous ne vous a pas échappé que
c'était du ressort de l'état
donc il faut se battre avec sa
population et c'est pas simplement en à
leurs envies en toc toc auprès du
ministère est évidemment on peut le
faire mais ça ne suffit pas si l'on
organise les motifs sur un territoire on
mobilise la population et on voit que la
mort la population tient à cet hôpital
puisque à dole la population tient à cet
hôpital on mobilise la population et
avec elle on va défendre l'hôpital
penser la chaise radan
les gens les habitants ce livre est
attaché hier sa vérité c'est illusoire
via son bière seront ils ont sauvé leur
maternité quête qui était elle n'est pas
en danger la maternité
mais ce qui m'étonne c'est que vous
comprenez pas que la chirurgie
conventionnelle et une ariane elle
mettait à rio par les insurgés à l'e10
les dynamiques et géorgiens de l'hôpital
dé leur ai discuté avec déchirure mais
les appareils de la maternité abinal une
dernière question à hervé ouais c'est
une question un petit peu taquine pour
vous et hervé près puisque vous avez dit
à jean baptiste gagne ou si vous perdez
l'élection ce que vous en doutez que
jean baptiste gagne ou puisse perdre
l'élection
j'ajuste jeudi un petit mot sur le lobby
les médecins il faut créer un centre de
santé ou une maison de santé
il ya trois ans monsieur jean marie
sermier l'a proposé et maintenant c'est
une promesse électorale de monsieur
gagnon il faut le faire et nous le
ferons ce que présent dans le projet
s'il est d'accord c'est une maison je
vais car clarifie les choses
vous avez pour projet une maison de
santé c'est à dire construire un projet
immobilier et faire venir deux dans des
professions de santé d'espèce il nous
donne nous on a un centre de santé c'est
à dire qu'on cherche à recruter
je réponds à votre question on cherche à
recruter des médecins et des soignants
des fonctionnaires la municipalité des
centres de santé mais lons le saunier
des métiers aux salariés qu'ils avaient
bien sûr autrement dit répond on
arrivait au terme de ce débat je vais
vous laisser à chacun d'entre vous 30
secondes pour conclure vous adresser à
vos électeurs il faut 30 secondes pour
les convaincre de vous choisir le 15
mars pour ce premier tour on reprend
l'ordre du début d'émission hervé prat
c'est à vous moi je pense qu'on le voit
aujourd'hui et puis dans les programmes
qui sont distribués que tous les partis
aujourd'hui on repeint leur programme en
verre je pense que les électeurs et les
électrices choisiront l'original
à la peinture verte et nous ne sommes
bien placés pour défendre donc
l'écologie au niveau local nous
souhaitons avec besançon anne vignot
avec dijon stéphanie modde avec dol
notre liste verte et ouverte créer un
réseau de villes vertes aussi travailler
avec les communes périurbaines et c'est
comme ça que nous répondrons à l'urgence
écologique
et puis à l'urgence sociale vous avez
fait pile 30 secondes je vous en
remercie jean baptiste ganne you we
doloise de loi depuis six ans la
majorité municipale que je conduis
c'était fort c'est de transformer notre
ville de lui donner plus d'éclat de
défendre ses services eh bien ça s'est
caractérisé par une augmentation de la
population en tissu économique meilleure
ou politique événementielle et culturel
qui permet à la ville de revivre ne
brisez pas ses talents et donc bien sûr
je propose un projet crédible sans
dogmatisme ouvert à la population à
l'écouté et je compte sur chacun d'entre
vous le 15 et 22 mars
merci jean baptiste gagnoa quoi hamdaoui
votre conclusion s'il vous plaît alors
je veux dire dolois ensemble puisque
notre liste s'appelle ensemble ensemble
nous créerons une ville plus écologique
capable de s'adapter aux changements
futurs due au changement climatique
ensemble on va créer une ville plus
agréable en défendant les services
publics que nous allons créer que nous
défendrons ensemble on va créer une
ville plus solidaire plus solidaire
auprès des seniors auprès des prudes et
plus fragile avec la création de moments
festifs
ensemble nous déciderons des grands
projets faut-il faire une piscine à 35
millions ou 1,11 million
c'est vous qui déciderez de l'ensemble
de ces projets et merci nos décisions
ici monsieur hamdaoui votre 30 secondes
sont écoulés à dominique voit votre
conclusion
alors voter pour la liste lutte ouvrière
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
c'est voter pour une liste qui est
résolument contre l'autre camp celui du
pouvoir et de l'argent et contre ceux
qui le défendent
c'est montrer qu'il existe à dole un
courant de travailleurs conscients
qu'ils refusent de se résigner et qui
est convaincu qu'il faudra s'attaquer au
pouvoir de la bourgeoisie
si on veut l'empêcher de nuire merci
dominique revoy merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé
à ce débat merci david c'est d'être
revenu sur ce plateau des bars voir bien
sûr en intégralité sur notre site
internet je vous souhaite à tous une
bonne fin de campagne premier tour le 15
mars je le rappelle nous rendez vous
d'ici là dimanche matin 11h25 le débat
dans la ville de saint claud mercredi
prochain en première partie de soirée le
débat à besançon très attendu également
à vesoul france soir votre chaîne de
proximité la chaîne des municipales
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]